Hello Freak bitches.
When people heard about this like and
you see the headlines and this is another
problem with clickbait journalism.
The headlines look like I
was fucking accused of rape.
There was one article that used
the word sexual harassment.
Sexual misconduct was
in all the headlines,
is that I have no thoughts and ideas.
I've seen that one about people connected
to Harvey Weinstein about Ben Affleck,
they called it sexual misconduct.
What does that mean?
Like something that you
don't think they should do.
What's really crazy?
Eagle and I almost lost a job.
I did just lose a gig because when you
google it's like sexual misconduct stuff
and like that's really scary and again,
I don't want to be like,
you know who the real victim
of Harvey Weinstein is?
Jamie Kilstein.
But like let me just stop you right here.
If you say like one more time,
I fucking head's going to explode.
Dude.
I get comments like that.
It's brutal.
It's a brutal.
Isn't as bad as.
All right.
I'm going to.
I just want you to slow it down.
I'm going to use it every now and then.
Flip this coffee over here,
breaking like the light meter.
I'm going to do it to men.
A lot of people do it.
It's an easy one to do
it switched to water.
But that word is a,
it's an,
it's a.
people use it as um,
I know,
I know.
It's okay.
I do it too.
We all do it,
but it just,
it's nice to know.
Yeah,
no,
I,
it's also a very progressive thing.
Like there's a way that people talk,
like when they're really progressive
that like you don't hear like left wing
people talk.
I keep getting fucked
over by the progressive's.
It's a way of appearing.
Um,
what's the word?
Submissive or
passive?
Yeah.
It's not a,
it's not an aggressive
way of communicating.
All right.
What if I said like,
but like I kept like punching the table,
like as I did it on a fucking like,
you know,
like go to like step to me
just smash up perhaps a can.
So,
so you got a bunch of people that were
upset at you because you had embodied the
quintessential allies.
So it was,
there was nobody had a reason to like
me or to defend me on one half of the
twittersphere you had progressives
who thought I was a sexual creep.
And then on the other half you
have comedy fans who were like,
fuck this dude.
He's the one who called everyone a sexist.
You don't need to read the
article if you see a headline.
I mean,
God,
I attacked so many people without
fucking reading the articles.
Of course there are people to this day
that will come up on citizen radio that I
don't know why I was mad at.
I would just figure out the story
as we were covering it and be like,
yeah,
fuck that guy.
I guess of course.
And so nobody.
There was no reason to root for me.
There wasn't a strong enough fan base.
It wasn't like if you know,
a,
a bigger comic gets accused of something.
Well he has thousands or millions of
fans and then this small community who
accused me of something
I had sort of nobody.
And when I burned all the bridges
and in comedy and you know,
I never just showed up at clubs
to do sets and stuff like that.
I just had this audience and sort
of thought I could never get fired,
you know?
Um,
like when w,
when Allie and I sort of became more
platonic before the open relationship.
I mean,
there were days it was,
it was.
So,
uh,
you know,
I mean I would sleep on the couch,
but there were days I would go on the
road and I would not cheat and I'll go
back to the hotel and jerk off and like,
my orgasm was better because I'm like,
I saved citizen radio.
Like I was trying so hard not to,
not to do anything like that.
And so anyway,
I lost.
Yeah,
there was no one to root for me.
I just had this small audience,
this small audience be thinks I'm a
Predator or they're too nervous to say
anything.
Well,
you fit the quintessential [inaudible].
There's a classic view of what a male
feminist is in that class in view is a
sneaky guy that is getting in tight with
women and saying all the things they
really want to hear and the classic
story is that those women are never
attracted to that guy anyway.
And went up and go and fuck some jocks.
I'm Alpha Guy.
I didn't mean that's
literally what happened.
I was like,
yeah,
you don't say like,
do you the royalty of is
this enormous movie empire.
Right.
And we find that particularly offensive.
This not just,
he's not just a creep trying to get laid.
He's a guy that was trying to hold that
power over people and use it against
them.
And then on top of that he
was like physically forceful.
So you've got like your worst case
scenarios and then you have guys that are
just trying to get laid and you're like,
okay,
how do you w w,
w we,
we demonizing aggressive heterosexuality.
Like where does this go?
Where does this go into sexual assault?
Like rubbing up against someone physically
touching them when they don't want
you to.
Well,
that's sexual assault,
but hitting on someone,
but
that doesn't seem like
sexual assault or anything.
It seems like someone
just trying to get laid,
like where does it?
But then when someone's,
the boss he go,
okay,
but then you're not supposed
to do that when you're a boss.
Right.
I,
I was,
I was very interested in the,
in the,
in the dynamic between what specifically
with Harvey Weinstein and his people
under him for many decades about it.
I was trying to put myself
in this position of like,
how does this stay quiet for so long?
Even though there's a little rumblings,
like they talk about Seth Mcfarlane's
joke at some award show Kevin Spacey to
break a little kid was
running away from silos.
We're locked in Kevin Spacey's basement.
It's,
it's amazing that this stuff is kind of
like an open secret but still doesn't
seep out or really.
And um,
it makes you think about the pie,
the power dynamics and how fearful people
are in these positions because it's
easy.
My initial instinct was like,
why didn't anyone say anything that
was similar to the bill cosby thing?
I'm like,
why didn't anyone say anything?
But then you realized
people were saying things.
They were,
they were being given hush money.
They were being shut up.
But these are really,
really bad people.
But I agree with you that it,
you know,
I've never been a um,
an aggressive flirt flirter as it were.
I've always been very passive with
women because I never really believed in
myself that much.
All that.
But
I've known people that have
been very flirtatious and,
and you know,
and all of that.
I'm like,
I wonder what is the line there now and,
and is it okay to,
to be flirtatious,
to call a woman beautiful at a bar or
to do something like that as opposed to,
you know,
kind of if a girl likes you,
that's the thing.
Like if you meet a girl at
a bar and the girl's like,
Colin is a really cool guy,
God,
I'm so into him and cons,
like,
you're really beautiful.
And she's like,
oh,
I gotta thank you.
And then next thing you know,
you guys are hanging out or
you meet a girl at a bar,
she has nothing.
She doesn't want to have
anything to do with you.
She's sober,
you're drinking your breath,
smells,
know,
like you're really beautiful.
And you're like,
oh gross,
get the fuck away from me.
You know,
it can be exactly the same attempt,
but the person is just not into you.
You become a creep.
Right?
Exactly.
So,
uh,
I'm uh,
I don't,
uh,
I don't look at the
situation now in 2017 with,
you know,
on college campuses and
all these things as,
as desirable for anyone because who
knows who the hell knows the rules of the
landscape,
you know,
now I think a lot of it just comes
down to mutual respect and all of that.
Unless you look at merit and character,
you're fucked.
Like if you're like,
I'm rather or not,
you think white people are special and
then you should keep them down or boost
them up.
It's both toxic.
I think like when it comes
to Rachel Dolezal like her,
her problem is not that she
wants to be black and she's not.
Her problem is that people give
a fuck about what she wants.
She just didn't have that language.
Just didn't like.
Imagine her whole world
could be exactly the same.
The way she behaves could
be exactly the same.
The way she dresses,
her actions,
everything.
If she didn't utter a few words that
like I'm actually black and people are
like,
wait what?
Like,
and then they go into her history.
No,
you want it to be black
but you weren't black.
You look
and that just quick,
quick,
quick.
It's just eyeballs.
Shaun king,
I mean he was a part of
black lives matter obviously.
He wanted to do good.
Obviously he wanted to spread
good ideas and help people.
The people that he really identified with,
if those tweets are real and I don't
know if they are Hashtag wrong skin and
Hashtag trans racial and all that stuff,
then that's literally how he felt.
He didn't feel it because
he hated those people.
He felt because he identified with them
and they're more attractive to him than
the than what he actually was.
So if he just Paul Walden and
never said to me Paul Wall,
right?
The wrapper with the grill.
I mean,
isn't that essentially
I have a deep love of,
of black American culture.
I mean there's a lot of people that
just will just be themselves and go in.
Just go in is what I appreciate more.
There's a lot of black people at golf
clubs with fucking Polo shirts on.
Right?
Why?
Because they identify with that culture.
It's appealing to them.
We'll just let people,
fucking cultures,
everything man.
That people.
And the irony is is like Joey Diaz,
he's going to get us grills.
You heard about that.
And the irony is is like
inner city black culture,
like
things like comes to my shows and thinks
I'm funny because they liked that crazy
shit.
Like man you fucking funny
tell to talk about things.
They just think it's funny.
I think when I say they,
it's annoying because it's like,
of course not all black
people finding funny,
but like that culture,
that black redneck,
white liberal culture,
it's like I'm from a culture that's more
similar to American southern or urban
black culture than a lot of the liberals
calling me names and it's just this
type of culture that bonds
through shit talking,
you know,
like Boston,
where it's like if you talk shifts,
someone's like,
oh,
you're dead,
you're dead x,
Oklahoma.
Michael Reese,
my dad's didn't kill himself.
You know?
And then your friends because it's like
you've hit the darkest shit and then
you're like,
oh,
we'll make it through a winter.